[Musique]
nounou je t'a dit quoi
c'est quoi qui te gêne
le soleil
était dit quoi tu peux éteindre
tu veux que j'éteins le soleil
ça va être chaud
je sais pas si j'ai ce pouvoir
alors moi je te propose un dîner aux
chandelles vraiment en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est de romantiser le
quotidien c'est à dire que tu peux très
bien faire ça chez toi mais modifier
l'apparence ça s'appelait aux femmes
oui bon
un gros bouquet de fleurs ou un petit
bouquet de fleurs selon ton budget
t'imagines un jour ta meuf elle a un
petit souci de santé mais toi un petit
souci de santé qui nécessite de la kiné
donc elle va chez le kiné une fois par
semaine pendant deux mois tu vois c'est
prescrit par le médecin
par semaine pendant deux mois et un jour
tu découvres que le kiné il a cette tête
là tu vois le genre de tête là
[Musique]